[Music]
action
have you told them lady grantham she's
told us nothing do
sit down i've come into possession of a
villa in the south of france what villa
start at the beginning
years ago before you were born i met a
man
they spend a few days together and he
gives her a house you never thought to
turn it down do i look as if i turned
down a villa in the south of france
a telephone call for you my lord mr
barber is a producer and director he
wants to make a film at dalton a moving
i think it's a horrible idea actresses
plastered in makeup and actors just
plastered there is something about it
like a wild animal ready to spring ready
to spring on you you mean
[Music]
why do you think he gave you the villa
that is where the mystery resides then
go off to the riviera and with any luck
we'd miss the whole of mary's frightful
film
i do hope that was a prop
you steer ahead
you're the captain now
better be warned
the british are coming
welcome to the villa of the doves it's a
beautiful place how happy you must be oh
my goodness who is she the lady grantham
i first went to work for granny
why did you invite us here
[Music]
it doesn't look good for papyrus without
the need to keep it a secret
there's trouble in paradise you don't
need me to tell you that marriage is a
novel full of plot twists along the way
women like us fall into two categories
dragons and fools you must make sure
they think of you as a dragon
with that i will say good night and
leave you to discuss my mysterious past
it seems the public only want films that
talk i should have thought the best
thing about films is that you can't hear
them be even better if you couldn't see
them either
[Music]
you